this episode is sponsored by Squarespace
go to squarespace.com microcosmos to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
[Music]
when you hear the phrase brain eating
amoebas is there a particular image that
comes to mind maybe you're Conjuring up
a malignant blob one that creeps and
eats and creeps some more its size
growing with every chunk it rips out of
your brain or maybe you're painting a
picture of a shape-shifting pac-man-like
organism bent on terrorizing your body
or maybe there's nothing just you know
the existential dread that happens when
you mash a bunch of seemingly unrelated
words together like brain eating and
amoeba only to realize the threat is
actually pretty real whatever you
envision or do not would it be strange
to suggest that the notorious brain
eating amoeba that strikes fear in our
hearts actually looks something like
these little guys like tiny little bits
of fluff that have just stumbled into
your path now to be very clear these are
not brain eating amoebas at least not as
far as we know they belong to the same
general group of organisms though called
amoeba flagellates and since we do not
you know have some brain eating microbes
on hand we are going to use these amoeba
flagellates as sort of a proxy as you
might guess from the name amoeba
flagellates take all of the crawling and
shape-shifting blobbiness that we love
from amoeba and combine it with the
flagella that powers flagellates it's
actually a little more complicated than
that and that is why we are focusing on
brain eating amoebas today because they
have actually been very well studied
because they impact human life pretty
substantially
in 1961 a nine-year-old boy died in
South Australia four years later two
eight-year-old girls died as well they
had been healthy but four days before
their deaths they reported feeling tired
the next day they all had painful
headaches along with a fever and other
symptoms around the same time a 28 year
old man arrived at the hospital with
similar symptoms and died shortly after
these cases were documented by Dr M
Fowler and they were all diagnosed with
meningitis an inflammation of the
membranes that protect the brain and
spinal cord meningitis can be caused by
bacterial or viral infections but when
doctors studied the bodies of the
patients after their death they did not
find any bacteria or viruses they found
amoeba this was a surprise there are
other amoebas that dig their way into
human tissues like entamoeba histolica
the parasite behind his diseases like
emibiasis and amoebic colitis but while
entamoeba histolica can lead to
meningitis it is an intestinal parasite
the organism that killed these patients
was something entirely different a free
living organism not a parasite that just
happened to find itself in a prime
position in a human nasal cavity to kill
the amoeba would later be named niglaria
fowleri for the Doctor Who first
described it and it is very important to
understand that nigleria fowleri does
not rely on our brains to survive
members of the Nigeria genus are found
all around the world in both Soil and
Water they swim around in lakes and
non-chlorinated Pools and Hot Springs
they can even be found in the nasal
passages of humans who are entirely
healthy ecologically these amoeba likely
play an important role in making sure
bacteria populations don't go out of
control by eating them and some like
naagleria fowleri love hot water which
is why they tend to proliferate in the
summer
nyglaria also change up their form
depending on the conditions around them
normally they exist in their amoeboid
form called atrophozoite but when food
is scarce or conditions become
unfriendly they might transition towards
their flagellated State and if things
get very very bad then nyglaria pull one
of the most popular moves in the
microcosmos they ball up into a
protective cyst putting themselves on
pause until things improve and they feel
ready to emerge
imagine Mike Laria spending their days
swimming around looking for bacteria to
eat and then curling up into cysts when
they feel they need the protection it's
all a bit quaint for a killer amoeba but
perhaps that is Nike Laria fowleri's
greatest transformation the one it
embarks on when it goes from water to a
human body that shift starts when it
inadvertently finds itself inhaled into
a nasal cavity usually by someone who's
been playing around or swimming in
infected water the nose might not be
where the amoeba is intended to be but
assigning intention in the microcosmos
is a pointless Endeavor the amoeba has
found itself in a new habitat and so it
must adapt
it begins by sticking itself to the
mucousy surfaces around it the body does
not welcome magleria fowleri within six
hours the immune system will attempt to
mount one of its first lines of Defense
using a type of white blood cells called
neutrophils to try and control the
amoeba and over the next few days the
amiibo will continue its path undeterred
by our body's defenses as it reaches the
olfactory bulb and along its path my
Glaria fowleri will release enzymes that
break down the olfactory epithelium it
passes by causing destruction that is
felt by the human whose body has become
an unwitting home to the amoeba
now we keep calling this a case of brain
eating amoeba but the disease itself is
actually called primary amoebic
meningoencephalitis and as we described
in the first reported cases the symptoms
are painful headaches vomiting fatigue
even coma patients usually die within a
week of these symptoms
and the good news is these infections
are not common between 1962 and 2018
there were 45 cases in the U.S the
country that has reported the most cases
of course this only accounts for
infections that were reported so there
may be more the bad news is that
survival is exceedingly rare only five
percent thanks to a drug called
amphotericin but if a treatment exists
then why is survival so rare well
remember that amoebas are not the only
organisms that cause meningitis so
narrowing down on Nigeria fowleri as the
culprit can be difficult and given the
rapid destruction of the amoeba but the
laid diagnosis can mean death
so what do we do with that what do we do
with the knowledge that out there in a
lake somewhere is an amoeba flagellate
capable with the release of a few
proteins and a trip down our nose of
killing us
[Music]
guess we do what we always do we watch
and learn and try to know more about a
vast World hiding around us a world
constantly undergoing tiny little
transitions between friend and foe or
perhaps more accurately a world where
friend and foe is a dichotomy too harsh
to grasp in the Myriad relationships in
between
foreign
for coming on this journey with us as we
explore the Unseen World that surrounds
us and thank you to Squarespace for
sponsoring this episode Squarespace
offers a robust platform that empowers
small businesses to create their own
websites whether you're just starting
out or looking to expand your existing
Venture Squarespace provides all the
essential features you need to succeed
maybe you're a talented yoga instructor
and want to establish a captivating
online presence for your studio
Squarespace provides you with the tools
to design a beautiful and professional
website that reflects your Studio's
tranquil Ambiance and captures the
essence of your teaching style utilizing
squarespace's third-party extensions you
can effortlessly manage class schedules
streamline bookings and offer online
yoga sessions to students around the
globe and if you're interested in
sharing your yoga knowledge and
inspiration with a broader audience
Squarespace makes it easy to integrate a
Blog seamlessly into your website you
can Enlighten your readers with
insightful articles yoga techniques and
mindfulness practices fostering a deeper
connection with your community you can
even engage with your students through
threaded comments and replies as you
encourage discussions offer guidance and
celebrate their progresses as they
embark on their yoga Journey you can
sign up for a free trial at
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch visit squarespace.com microcosmos
to enjoy a 10 discount on your first
purchase of a website or domain
thank you so much to all the people
whose names are on the screen right now
they are some of our patreon patrons the
people who make it possible to make this
show it always makes me feel so good to
see these names people who just want to
make it possible for us to continue on
this journey which has been a really
wonderful part of my life so thank you
so much to all those folks if you want
to become one of them you can go to
patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
thank you